an elite core of the world's best
trained warriors gathers in the name of
science
to push their bodies to their physical
limits
the strength and stamina of Navy SEALs
the speed and focus of Green Berets the
lightning reflexes of Israeli commandos
these guys perform at superhuman levels
they truly are in a class by themselves
the go test their peak performance under
environmental extremes
today's mission place this seal under
the freezing conditions of hypothermia
and see if it impairs his physical and
tactical performance the tools of the
test include an obstacle course a
shooting gallery and a giant tank of ice
water
the water has reached a chilling level
about 55 degrees Fahrenheit
the scientists expects to to last no
longer than 30 minutes before they'll
have to pull him out of this icy bath
how's it feel let's go keep breathing
neat
heart rate went up to a hundred the cold
water is a sudden shock to the body
he's immersed him for an hour in
ice-cold water and looking at he's cold
he's fatigued he's stressed
we've got him to the position where he
is getting uncomfortable physically he's
uncomfortable mentally now we're going
to see how we perform in the exact same
scenario we put him in before now the
true test obstacle course and firing
range
Kenny matches earlier performance when
his muscles were taking and stiff when
his mind wasn't fatigued when his motor
skills weren't impaired by the freezing
cold can he even perform the drill at
all stewey ready ready three two one
good yeah you got to see this
Phil come here show me where you're hit
right between the eyes look at that and
in the hand hands in the center body
mass of the target when he's presenting
the firearm
good shooting brother hey good job under
stress under adversity under extreme
cold Stu Smith outlasted normal test
subjects and now performed himself when
placed in the line of fire
that's what special operations are all
about